all right house of the Dragon What's it
gonna be this week
[Music]
all right foot fetish it is yes this
episode has all the foot rubbing action
that would make even Quentin Tarantino
blush they look wonderful if you really
pay me enough we'll massage your feet in
any of these sauces also honestly my
intros get worse every week well if that
doesn't lorus you're strong how about
kid fight club you do not talk about
Fight Club in this video there are some
absolutely huge differences from the
book which may have implications for the
entire season going forward we'll also
be looking at Easter eggs connections to
the book and a whole lot more but be
sure to like And subscribe as tomorrow
I'll be coming out with my preview
breakdown which will have tons of
spoilers if you've been an insane person
like me and watch the intro credits
every week you'll have noticed slight
changes from episode to episode for
example King viserys's sigil can now be
seen overtaken by Blood which is
something reserved only for those
characters who have died this is the
first episode where we get to see
Allison's bloodline more closely here is
Alison with the Hightower of Old Town in
front of the seven-pointed star of the
faith her blood flows downward toward
her four children aegon Eamon Helena and
daeron now you might be asking yourself
where is this missing fourth child how
come we haven't seen him yet that would
be because he's not even in King's
Landing having taken up the position as
Squire for Allison's cousin Lord Ormond
high tower in Old Town the sigils for
each child are pretty straightforward a
spider for Helena whose love for insects
extends even to her embroidery a woman
bound aegon's penchant for doing things
to women against their will and a
sapphire for Eamonn who in the book is
said to have put this gem in place of
his missing eye unfortunately we can't
really make out dayrons but we'll
probably get that in season 2 when it
said his character will appear now skip
ahead about 30 seconds if you don't want
a minor spoiler regarding King aegon in
Helena's children we do see a bloodline
flowing downward from King aegon II to
their three children jaharis Jahara and
mayor is of course named after viserys's
grandfather who named him king after the
great Council he and Jahira were twins
which would explain their identical
sigils this one was a bit more difficult
and let me know if I'm wrong here but
since we traveled down from Damon I'm
assuming these two are his two sons with
rhaenyra aegon the younger and viserys
who we saw briefly in last episode there
is a third child on the way as we do see
rhaenyra was pregnant last episode a
dark Throne sits empty for the first
time in 26 years the length of King
viserys's Reign the keep his quiet and
dark save for a servant boy emerging
from the king's Chambers it's never
mentioned what this kid was doing there
but since he works under Allison's
handmaiden Talia who in turn works for
the White Worm masaria it's a safe bet
he was tasked with checking on the king
at talia's behest there's a lot to be
gained by being the first to know of the
king's demise and can I just say I loved
getting a glimpse of The Quiet Castle
but down below you have all the servants
already be prepping for the day it's
these small details that really get me
immersed in the world Talia tells the
queen of her husband's passing this has
been a long time coming and Allison asks
that she stay confined to this room that
will be a big theme throughout the
episode keeping the death of the king a
secret until Allison in the greens can
sort everything out Talia will use her
time in the Queen's Chambers to light
some candles near the window a sign to
messaria below that the King has passed
this is how messaria was able to grab
aegon and hide him in the sept I also
found it pretty ironic that messaria
used her knowledge of aegon's
whereabouts to make a deal with Otto to
shut down that toddler UFC when it was
aegon who loved frequenting them more on
why masaria asked for this in a bit a
distraught Allison picks at her nails
something that's been a sign of her
anxiety throughout the entire season she
tells her father hand of the king Otto
Hightower that on his deathbed King
viserys wished for aegon to be king and
Otto is sitting there like
this statement is category untrue not
once did the king say he wished aegon to
be king viserys and his delirium from
drinking milk of the poppy and likely
half dead was referring to aegon the
Conqueror in episode 1 we learned of
aegon's Prophecy which foretold of a
Targaryen ruler needed to unite the
realm against an upcoming evil a nod to
the night King and his army of the Dead
which won't appear for about another 150
years in fact the cat's paw dagger which
tells this prophecy when heated by Flame
is the very dagger that will end up
killing the night King so Allison ends
up interpreting viserys's mumbo-jumbo as
him wanting aegon their son on the
throne the small Council has been
summoned and considering the name of
this episode is the green Council it
becomes quickly apparent why in
attendance are Jasper Wilde a master of
laws Grand maester Orwell Lyman
beesberry master of coin Thailand
Lannister master of ships hand of the
king Otto Hightower sir Christian Cole
and Lord commander of the king's artist
sir Harold westerling Otto Begins the
meeting by declaring the death of King
viserys who he calls the peaceful pretty
ironic considering the Bloodshed his
death is about to cause it's also
interesting because viserys was so
concerned how the people would remember
him and it seems Otto has made that
decision he'll later refer to the former
King as viserys the peaceful in his
speech to the common folk at the dragon
pit we've never got an explanation as to
the purpose of these marble balls that
indicate a member's attendance to the
council they're not mentioned in the
book But Otto does something interesting
here only after he tells the Council of
King viserys's Last Wish does he put the
ball in its holder almost as if when the
ball is in they're on record and out off
the Record if you think they're used for
something else let me know in the
comments Ravens are to be sent to Green
allies in River Run and highgarden
giving them advanced warning to prepare
and it seems as though every member on
the council minus Allison and Lyman
beesberry has been planning for this
event with Otto immediately demanding
that two captains of the city watch
still loyal to Damon be replaced
remember that Damon used to command them
it's absolutely crazy to think that the
friggin Queen was not let in on this
treacherous plan something she'll no
doubt resent Tylen Lannister would no
doubt be on Team Green his brother Jason
after all was snubbed by rhaenira as a
potential husband and tylan's advice was
often overlooked by the old King such as
what to do in the stepstones he tells
Otto that the treasury will be divided
for safe keeping which is something
that's news to master of coin Lyman
beesberry he calls this whole thing
treason hundreds of Lords pledged their
fields to lady raniera and now we're
supposed to believe that King's dying
words to a queen who seeks to put her
son on the throne it's possible that
Lyman could have made it out of this
meeting alive if it weren't for his
accusation that one of them including
Allison poisoned the king something her
sworn protector sir Kristen Cole does
not take too kindly to Smashing his head
into the table and killing him the book
offers three different accounts as to
how this went down one that Lyman was
taken to the dungeon where he died of a
chill two that sir Kristen Cole stabbed
him in the throat and three that Kristen
flung him out of a window but they all
agree that Lyman beesberry was the first
to perish in the dance of dragons the
Civil War that's to brew between the
Allison's Team Green and Rainier is team
Black beesbury's Death is enough for
Harold westerling to demand sir Kristen
remove his sword and cloak and Tyler
tries to get out of the way like yeah uh
let me get out of your way or while the
man of medicine that he is thinks it's
best to remove beesbury's body But Otto
stresses the importance of keeping
everyone there every moment renera does
not know of her father's passing is a
moment they can organize their forces a
vital Ally for the greens would be house
Baratheon at Storm's end led by boros
the son of Borman Baratheon who he saw
in episodes 1 tournament and also in
episode 5 during rhaenyra's search for a
Suitor it can be inferred that sometime
between episode 5 and 9 that Borman died
leaving star forms and taboros and his
four daughters if boros were offered
amend or daeron to Wed one of his
daughters it may sway him to join the
greens Allison feels trapped everything
is out of her control renice believes
the Queen's desire is not to be free but
to make a window in the wall of her
prison we saw some amazing framing in
episode 8 that showed her like a caged
bird one of the main conflicts between
Allison and her father is what's to be
done with rhaenyra Allison wants to give
her Fair terms to bend the knee in the
book it is said that if renira bent the
knee she'd be able to keep Dragon stoned
to pass it on to Jace while driftmark
would pass on to Luke in the show Otto
orders Harold westerling to take the
kingsguard to Dragonstone and have
rhaenyra and her kin killed in the book
Harold isn't never in this meeting and
died more than a decade earlier with
Kristen having already been replaced as
Lord Commander for several years so when
Harold westerling removes his cloak not
wanting to undertake these orders from
someone other than the king we aren't
sure sure what happens to him he just
kind of walks away I like to imagine
he's on the beach enjoying pina coladas
enjoying his retirement that or getting
rowdy on the street of silk as morning
Dawn's Helena watches over her two
children jaharis and Jahira we mentioned
earlier Alice and has come with the news
that her father has died and she demands
to know where aegon is Helena here lets
out one of her cryptic lines the same
one we heard her mutter in episode 8 at
dinner
Helena is no stranger to these cryptic
prophecies in episode 6 she said that
Eamon will have to quote close an eye
when he rides a dragon and in episode 7
she says quote hand turns Loom spool of
green spool of black dragons of Flesh
weaving dragons of thread foreshadowing
the dance of dragons if you want to find
out who this Beast beneath the boards is
make sure you're subscribed for when I
come out with my preview breakdown
videos which are filled with spoilers
aemond is also here and as we'll see in
his storyline this episode this is a man
who wants to be king while his brother
aegon doesn't want it I also like how
the production design team made these
sweet seven-pointed star candle holders
Auto visit Sir Eric Cargill the sworn
protector of Prince aegon he has a twin
brother whose name sounds very similar
Arc with an a I would hate growing up in
that house in the book even the fellow
kingsguard couldn't tell these two apart
and I think that's what the writers are
trying to do here so if I screw up in
Eric with an arc you can feed me to the
dragons the prince evaded Eric's
protection and now Otto has tasked him
and his brother with retrieving the
Future King Allison will task Kristen
and Eamon with this as well because
whoever gets their hand on aegon May
wind up determining the fate of rhaenyra
and the war to come there's also this
really weird moment in the scene where
Allison Whispers to Kristen outside of
eamon's earshot
everything you feel for me is your queen
did any of you think that was weird too
and if the King's Landing Hospitality
couldn't get any worse renice is
awakened to find herself locked in her
room she clearly showed her allegiance
to reniera last episode by siding with
Luke's claim to the Driftwood Throne so
Allison has her locked away until she
agrees to side with the greens through
her window she can see other Lords and
Ladies ushered away likely to the Great
Hall where Otto will demand they swear
fealty to aegon if you look really
closely you can see Grand maester Orwell
Jasper and Thailand scheming here off to
the side meanwhile Talia and other
servants are brought to the dungeon in
the book those deemed to be loyal to
renira were brought here to be
imprisoned or even killed with lorus
creeping around here and knowing that
Talia was one of masaria's informants I
think it's safe to say he was involved
in her capture her being Alison's
trusted handmaiden she otherwise
wouldn't have been there later in the
episode when Lord Caswell is caught
fleeing to inform rhaenyra he calls
Loris Lord Confessor which I believe is
the first time Laura has has been
referred to as such in the book that is
his title and it's meant for the Royal
torturer he also served as master of
Whisperers under both viserys and aegon
II however we've yet to see him
officially in that capacity Eamon knows
all of his brother's favorite hangout
spots in King's Landing in fact it was
aegon who brought Eamon to the street of
silk on his 13th birthday to lose his
virginity they'll actually interview the
woman he lost it to how you've heard
unfortunately aegon has not visited the
brothel as we'll find out later he
enjoys a very different type of
entertainment in the Great Hall Otto
demands the Lord's pledge their fealty
to aegon but not all of them believe
viserys changed his mind on his deathbed
among them is Lord Meriwether of long
table a noble house from the reach you
can tell by the house sigil on his
necklace in the book he along with Lady
fell and Lord Castle languished in the
dungeons for some time and are given one
last chance to swear fealty to aegon
when they refuse they are beheaded now
Caswell here knowing his next on the
line originally swears fealty but if you
notice Lars is off to the side watching
everyone and if I'm Larsen see this look
on a dude's face I'll definitely be
keeping an eye on him Eamon suggests
that aegon not wanting to be king is
probably halfway to E.T by now E.T is a
Far Eastern civilization yet to be seen
in the show however there's apparently
an animated spin-off called the Golden
Empire currently in the works that set
there the Cargill twins have found their
way to kids fight club Eric uses this
opportunity to show his brother how
cruel the Future King really is even
having his bastard children fight
although it's debatable whether he
actually knows they're his bastards
remember it was Eric who informed the
queen of aegon's abuse of Diana as his
sworn protector he probably knows all
the evil [ __ ] this kid's gotten up to
auric will counter saying none of that
matters this is their sworn Duty so I
think this is what will eventually set
these two brothers apart honor versus
Duty bonus points if you got the kids
wearing house emblems on the back of
their rags out of the blue Jane one of
masarya's underlings informs the twins
she knows where aegon is but if they
want to know they'll have to arrange a
meeting between Otto and the white worm
herself speaking of Otto he thinks Lars
who caught Lord Caswell trying to escape
but there's also a Veiled Threat here
when Otto notices Lars has spent quote
many hours with the queen and lorus
doesn't deny it saying there's no reason
those hours could not in the end benefit
you this is what makes Loris so
dangerous in the book The historians
never really knew what side lorus was
playing the silent sisters prepare
viserys's body in the book it was days
before they were even allowed to begin
their work as the body sat rotting
Allison lays the crown atop his corpse
as aegon will be taking a different
crown that of aegon the Conqueror when
he ascends rhaenys credits Alison for
her boldness when she comes with her
terms join her in the greens and she may
have drift Mark if she so wishes and
Allison has some good arguments here
Rainey supported the targaryens her
entire life and look what it got her a
dead daughter in pentos and a cuckolded
son but perhaps there's something that's
pissed rainist off more than anything
and that's that her life and Allison's
have been dictated entirely by men
rhaenyra would be the first female ruler
and that's something Alison can't offer
has Alison never imagined how things
would be different if she were on the
throne Kristen and Eamonn watch on as
Otto meets with messaria I don't know
she's not bullshitting him as she knows
the king is dead in exchange for the
prince's whereabouts she asks for the
end of the abhor treatment of children
in flea bottom where members of the gold
cloaks are bribed to look the other way
for messaria this is personal she grew
up in a world of child slaves brothels
and violence sold countless times and
used his property she knows what it's
like in episode 2 she even tells Damon
that she came to him not for gold power
or station but to be liberated by making
this deal with Otto she is hoping to
give these children something Damon
could not give her Liberation from fear
I don't know knows that messaria could
have just easily had aegon killed and
takes her up on the offer promising that
he will remember these terms once aegon
comes to power and aegon is in a spot
you'd least likely find him a sept the
same one his mother and raniera prayed
at as children in the book aegon is
found passed out naked in a flea bottom
rat pit where he is picked up by Sir
Kristen no battle takes place between
him and arik it's in this scene that
Eric defects going against both Otto's
orders and turning against his brother
we'll later see him as the one who helps
rhaenice Escape Alison now has the upper
hand whoever controls aegon can dictate
what happens next whatever their
differences Otto wants the two to be as
one but Alison isn't sure that's true
Alison wants Fair term sent to renera
But Otto being the realist that he is
says if she lives her allies will rally
behind her looking for her return all
Alison wants is to allow renira the
chance to save herself and auto
questions if this sentiment is coming
from what viserys would have wanted or
Alison herself in addition Allison wants
Kristen Cole named Lord commander of the
kingsguard and for aegon to be coronated
tomorrow morning with all of King's
Landing in attendance he'll also wear
aegon's crown and wield his sword a
blackfyre the same sword we saw of
viserys hold the scene ends rather
creepily with Otto telling his daughter
she looks so much like her mother in
certain lights perhaps he admires the
strength she finally shows playing The
Game of Thrones but for me I just found
it weird remember in episode 1 he told
her to wear one of her mother's dresses
after he tasked her with cozying up with
the King speaking of creeps Lars always
manages to find himself in the Queen's
Chambers it seems as though his
information now comes at a cost with
Allison having to provide him a free
only fan subscription I think it's kind
of ironic that the guy who can't use his
foot has a foot fetish he tells her that
within the castle is a web of spies Otto
has used this web to his Advantage for
example that's how he found out about
Ramirez tryst with her uncle in episode
4. the only way to destroy this web is
to kill killed the Weaver who I believe
to be messaria and Loris can do this for
her if she wishes of course that comes
with a far greater much stickier price I
am never gonna financially recover from
this Bernice still imprisoned and
thinking whether or not she'll accept
Allison's offering is awoken in the
middle of the night by Eric he's come to
help her Escape I found something really
interesting with Sir Eric his super cute
man purse this is an item he's not
wearing in his first scene with Otto I
actually have a theory as to what's
inside it but I'll save that for my
preview breakdown hint I mentioned it in
this video we see Lord Caswell hung in
the courtyard to be made an example of
those who defy the king there's also
this lingering shot of rhenice looking
upon the skull of valerian she would
have been alive when viserys wrote him
back in the day and it's also a reminder
that her own dragon Melise is over at
the dragon pit however with this Escape
it's too dangerous to claim her the two
make their way of the same passage
rhaenyra and Damon used in episode 4.
they're on their way to Blackwater Bay
to presumably gain passage to
Dragonstone and it looks like lorus has
already got his plans underway to chop
the head off the Weaver as we see
missarya's home burning this was likely
committed by one of his tongueless
cloaked henchmen who also created that
fire that killed Harwin and Lionel
strong we're not sure if misaria
actually dies in this fire but all I'll
say is that this does not happen in the
book Eric and renice are split apart
from one another as a deluge of citizens
are forced to attend the king's
Ascension kinda like those mandatory
School assemblies the book actually
offers differing accounts of how many
attended one stating that it was packed
to the brim and another that barely half
of the Arena was filled as preparations
are made we get a brief glimpse of this
prayer to the seven above which has this
really cool Easter egg talking about a
cataclysm on a sept that resulted in the
creation of the Dragon pit before the
dragon pits at a building called the
SEPTA remembrance which king maegor the
cruel burned down using valerian's
dragonflame during an event known as the
faith militant Uprising a few years
later the dragon pit as we know it would
be built atop these ruins even as his
Carriage makes its way to the pit aegon
does not want to be king stating that
his father had 20 years to do so but
never did what we'll see between now and
the end of the episode is aegon going
from I don't want it to this is kind of
cool all it takes is offering that sweet
cat's paw dagger and the Roar of some
adoring fans and pretty soon he's
getting everyone all worked up and I
kind of felt like he was enjoying it but
before we get to that Allison tells
aegon that Otto will try to convince him
to kill rhaenyra but to reject that he
doesn't even answer her asking instead
if she loves him to which she says you
imbecile a big leap from last episode
where she said he's not her son as
people attend the Travis Scott concert
and crammed into the dragon pit auto
announces that the King has died and
that his final wish was for aegon to be
king at first people are like I don't
know about this Wayne but slowly they
give in to uproarious Applause most
common folk always wanted a male to be
king and we saw this play out in episode
4. oh would she be feeble
aegon is brought forth under this cool
procession of saluting swords and my God
every entrance in this damn show is just
so friggin epic in attendance are
Kristen Grand maester Orwell Jasper
Wilde it's Highland Lannister Eamon
Helena Allison and Otto not here is
aegon's younger brother daeron who'll be
squirre in Old Town at the moment in
whom I'm told will appear in season 2.
the Targaryen emblem here is also gold
instead of a traditional red it is said
that when aegon took the crown he
switched it to gold which would also
match his gold dragon Sunfire rhaenys
Irish goodbyes the Ascension while aegon
is Anointed with the seven in the book
this is done by septon Eustis who
happens to be one of the sources from
the book Fire and Blood that being said
renice flying out of the Dragon pit on
Baileys killing hundreds and escaping
does not happen in the book but damn
does it make for some good TV but first
just like in the book aegon is crowned
by Kristen Cole with the red ruby
adorned crown of the Conqueror as he's
presented to the people they're a bit
hesitant at first but go along with it
aegon really gets into it thrusting the
air with his sword of Blackfire but with
any happy event in the Game of Thrones
Universe you know it'll be short-lived
maylese breaks through the pit
absolutely crushing those around her as
much as I hate Allison shout out to her
for immediately getting in front of her
son to protect him but here's what I
found most interesting and arguably one
of the most debated and controversial
changes from the book rhaenis has the
opportunity to kill basically all the
greens here and prevent the upcoming
Civil War all she had to do was yell
dracarus but she doesn't she lets them
live because this is not in the book and
the episode essentially ends here all we
can really do is speculate until next
week no doubt Rainier will want to know
why she didn't off them I have two
theories here which will probably get
disproven next episode one is that for
the first time renice gets to make her
own decision she may be the queen Who
Never Was but in this moment she holds
all authority over those in front of her
she is showing the queen she would have
been by sparing them them the second
theory and not my favorite is that she's
waiting on what to do until she hears
from Corliss last episode we heard he
was a few days away from arriving at
driftmark after suffering a serious
injury at Sea maybe she wants to consult
with him on which side to join but I
like the first Theory better a quick
update I did just watch the behind the
scenes footage where showrunners Ryan
Condell and Miguel sapochnik state that
it's renice's moral standpoint that
prevents her from killing them she does
not want to kill another mother whether
you agree with that decision or not is a
whole other question but I'll leave a
link to the behind the scenes video in
the description for those of you who are
interested and the episode ends with
maylese flying off to Freedom leaving
Allison and aegon in the darkness of the
Dragon pit it's also ironic since
rhaenys told Allison she was basically a
prisoner herself however renice ends up
free and Allison with the Gate of the
Dragon pit hiding her in darkness now we
only have one more episode to go until
the finale which means one more preview
breakdown which should be up within 24
hours of this video if you liked the
video and my work on this series it
really helps me out if you give it a
like and leave a comment thanks for
watching everyone and for more bad takes
you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember they look wonderful if you
really pay me enough we'll massage your
feet in any of these sauces also